dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with karoly zsolnai-feher in this
project openai built a hide and seek
game for their ai agents to play while
we look at the exact rules here i will
note that the goal of the project was to
pit two ai teams against each other and
hopefully see some interesting emergent
behaviors
and boy did they do some crazy stuff the
coolest part is that the two teams
compete against each other and whenever
one team discovers a new strategy the
other one has to adapt kind of like an
arms race situation and it also
resembles generative adversarial
networks a little and the results are
magnificent amusing
weird you'll see in a moment
these agents learn from previous
experiences and to the surprise of no
one for the first few million rounds we
start out with pandemonium
everyone just running around aimlessly
without proper strategy and semi-random
movements the seekers are favored and
hence win the majority of the games
nothing to see here
then over time the hiders learn to lock
out the seekers by blocking the doors
off with these boxes and started winning
consistently i think the coolest part
about this is that the map was
deliberately designed by the open ai
scientists in a way that the hiders can
only succeed through collaboration they
cannot win alone and hence they are
forced to learn to work together which
they did quite well
but then something happened did you
notice this pointy doorstop shaped
object
are you thinking what i'm thinking
well probably and not only that but
about 10 million rounds later the ai
also discovered that it can be pushed
near a wall and be used as a ramp and
tada
got him the seeker started winning more
again
so the ball is now back on the court of
the hiders can you defend this if so how
well these resourceful little critters
learned that since there is a little
time at the start of the game when the
seekers are frozen apparently during
this time they cannot see them so why
not just sneak out steal the ramp and
lock it away from them
absolutely incredible look at those
happy eyes as they are carrying that
ramp
and you think it all ends here
no no no not even close it gets weirder
much weirder when playing a different
map a seeker has noticed that it can use
a ramp to climb on the top of a box
and
this happens
do you think couchsurfing is cool give
me a break this is box surfing and the
scientists were quite surprised by this
move as this was one of the first cases
where the seeker ai seems to have broken
the game what happens here is that the
physics system is coded in a way that
they are able to move around by exerting
force on themselves but there is no
additional check whether they are on the
floor or not because who in their right
mind would think about that as a result
something that shouldn't ever happen
does happen here and we are still not
done yet this paper just keeps on giving
a few hundred million rounds later the
hiders learned to separate all the rams
from the boxes
dear fellow scholars this is proper box
surfing defense
then lock down the remaining tools
and build a shelter
note how well rehearsed and executed
this strategy is
there is not a second of time left until
the seekers take off
i also love this cheeky move where they
set up the shelter right next to the
seekers and i almost feel like they are
saying yeah see this here there's not a
single thing you can do about it in a
few isolated cases other interesting
behaviors also emerge for instance the
hiders learn to exploit the physics
system and just chuck the ramp away
after that the seekers go what what just
happened
but don't despair and at this point i
would also recommend that you hold on to
your papers because there was also a
crazy case where a seeker also learned
to abuse a similar physics issue and
launch itself exactly onto the top of
the hiders
man
what a paper
this system can be extended and modded
for many other tasks too so expect to
see more of these fun experiments in the
future we get to do this for a living
and we are even being paid for this i
can't believe it
in this series my mission is to showcase
beautiful works that light a fire in
people and this is no doubt one of those
works great idea
interesting unexpected results crisp
presentation bravo open ai love it
so did you enjoy this what do you think
make sure to leave a comment below also
if you look at the paper it contains
comparisons to an earlier work we
covered about intrinsic motivation
shows how to implement circular
convolutions for the agents to detect
their environment around them and more
this episode has been supported by
weights and biases weights and biases
provides tools to track your experiments
in your deep learning projects it can
save you a ton of time and money in
these projects and is being used by open
ai toyota research stanford and berkeley
in this blog post they show you how to
use their system to find clues and steer
your research into more promising areas
make sure to visit them through 1db.com
papers wand
papers or just click the link in the
video description and sign up for a free
demo today our thanks to weights and
biases for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and i'll see you next
time